so I was asked to speak to the topic of
developing vernacular eurasian resources
then and now and I chose to extend my
comments to not only cover then and now
but to also talk about then and now and
then because what I really want to focus
on is important trends and developments
as they're defining not so much where
we've been and where we find ourselves
but most importantly where I think we
are going my remarks also will focus at
a pretty high level looking at the
research library of the context in which
eurasian collections have and will be
developed and used by students and
scholars i'm hoping that in this
afternoon session will translate some of
these ideas into perhaps more practical
thinking about where we're research
libraries are going but i really want to
push this to a level of discussion and
thinking that really challenges us not
only to focus on the eurasian
collections but the larger sphere of
academic research libraries where we
find ourselves and where perhaps we
think we are going in that context I've
been working over the last several
months on developing a let's make sure
we get the technology working properly
okay developing sort of a grand scheme
if you will about the history current
state and future development of the
academic research library I would argue
that prior to nineteen fifty there were
actually several handfuls of libraries
that by current definitions we would
describe as research libraries I think
this was a period of exclusivity of a
small number of libraries on the East
Coast major research universities in the
center and on the west coast of the
country that were actually developing
collections of breadth and depth that
we would define the current context of
as as research libraries and therefore i
think the number of collections of your
asian material of eurasia materials that
would allow scholars to come in and do
substantive work we're actually quite
few we'd like to think of columbia as
being part of that york public is being
part of that but i think it's only after
nineteen fifty of a period of
popularization i would argue when we see
not only an explosion of the number of
academic research libraries across north
america largely governed by the
increasing investment by the federal
government in universities as the
research centers of the the nation of
the expanded increase in international
and global affairs and therefore the
growing international foreign language
collections in a lot of our libraries
and the massive growth in the student
populations therefore the need for more
universities the need for more faculty
and just an engine of growth that define
that period up until nineteen seventy of
i enter the library field just after
1970 and it was a period of the next two
decades that i would describe as a
period of discord i think it's a period
in which we see the entrance of
technology into a relatively
conservative analog environment it's the
period of time where we see the online
catalogs beginning to replace the card
catalogs we see interesting and
challenging labor-management growth of
unions in universities and libraries we
see the publishers becoming increasingly
vilified as as not supporting the
academy but supporting the stockholders
of the for-profit publishers and so for
the next 22 years there's just quite a
bit of angst in the community even as i
believe that collections grew all the
budgets were challenged i think it was a
period in which foreign language
eurasian collections continue to be very
strongly supported in
anced and it's in this period after
nineteen ninety I call it a period of
decadence when electronic publishing
really takes root and libraries of all
types all academic libraries of all
types across North America are able to
build strong research collections with
significant retrospective holdings so
it's not just those those exclusive
institutions that were able to build
those collections prior to nineteen
fifty but suddenly thanks to the growing
consortium purchasing of collections by
libraries thanks to the increasing
packaging of information the
digitization of historical collections
by publishers both here in Europe and
and in the former Soviet republic we
begin to see community colleges liberal
arts colleges small universities being
able to make available large quantities
of historical collections research
collections that had previously been the
province of the of the major research
universities and we also see deep
rigorous interlibrary loan document
delivery capacity developing among the
library community and so it's a period
in which I think will look back on as a
period of tremendous growth and
potential in the availability of
information through technology and
through cooperation I think the economic
context economic realities that struck
in 09 Oh 10 I think are creating what I
call a period of para by OSIS you can
say well where'd you get that word from
well para by OSIS is a biological term
it basically describes organisms that
share body parts and share systems and I
believe we're seeing a period in which
we're moving beyond tour of the kumbaya
of the of the 1970s to 2010 where
libraries held hands and work together
closely and we're seeing I think a much
more radical coming together of research
libraries in order to sustain the
capacity to build and make available
large collections of international
materials we can't do it independently
so we're developing strategies to do it
collaboratively and not
the traditional cooperation sense but
through new types of combinations and
integration of our work in our resources
and I believe after 2020 my prediction
is we're going to be in a period of
particularism where every academic
library if you will will have the
capacity to make available large
quantities of research materials and
what will define a research library is
the breadth and depth of the
infrastructure the expertise the ability
to bring that content into the teaching
and learning of research and scholarly
environments and I believe in that
context there will be several handfuls
of libraries that will have the depth
and breadth of your Asian expertise and
capacity to really support the work of
scholars like you around this table so
this is sort of the grand scheme that I
put out for your you're thinking about
the history current state and future
development I believe that under the
current in the current context where we
have not only the challenges of economy
and we have the challenges of Technology
the investments that we need to make
moving forward is I see a pretty
broad-based reduction in the commitment
and capacity of research libraries to
collect and to service and to preserve
global publications and resources in all
formats I see a very narrowing group of
libraries that in fact have the capacity
to do this I think it's also true that
we're getting a lot of new thinking
around how we're going to work together
how these collaborations will come
together but I think up until recently
these collaborations have generally been
shallow they've been episodic and they
have been selective there's not a
national strategy around how we build
international collections in support of
learning and research in North America
and I think that as a result of these
two trends global education and global
research as we know it will be
influenced by this reduced library
reduced library capacity to actually
make these collections available we used
to talk about them the most important
research collections in foreign
languages
being available institutionally and
collectively in North American research
libraries I believe that increasingly is
not the case and therefore we're seeing
international collaboration in
international working relationships
between North America and research
libraries and libraries in Europe and
around the world as a fundamental part
of our ability to serve our communities
it's very interesting that over the last
several months we've had a major major
legal pushback from North American and
Western European publishers on our
ability to share and exchange materials
outside the United States with other
countries which raises the question
whether at the very point that we are
reliant on international interlibrary
loan and document delivery the
publishers are raising legal challenges
under international copyright law about
our ability to in fact do that so we're
facing not only the economic challenges
we're facing sort of the the
infrastructure expertise challenges but
now we're also facing some legal
challenges to be able to support your
work and the work of other scholars let
me let me suggest that if at any point
there's something that I've said that
you would like to follow up on have a
discussion about all that will have some
opportunity just after noon to talk
about a lot of these issues just jump in
going to take through a number of ideas
but at any point you think it's
worthwhile to kick something around
please jump in we have some definitional
problems as well as we talk about these
issues I was raised if you will as a
Russian studies area studies librarian
now we talk about global resources
although we used we tend to use these
words interchangeably and the reason why
definitions and vocabulary important is
because as we engage the research
community and the faculty in discussions
about some of these questions we need to
have some commonality of language in
order to not only work with each other
and understand each other but also to
advocate with university
administration's and with public policy
leadership in Washington we've now got
this debate
over regional studies versus global
studies at Columbia we have about forty
percent of our student body are people
who come from other countries to study
at Columbia and we're finding that when
they top when they tackle a global
problem where they really want to work
in terms of their research in terms of
their of their theses they want to focus
on a particular problem in the context
of that global issue from their home
country from their home region so one
could argue that you know yes we're
building this more multidisciplinary
interdisciplinary strategy around
international development but when it
comes down to it people actually want to
work in a particular country or
particular region and therefore the
importance of having those collections
those vernacular foreign collections are
important to support the work of those
scholars we also as I mentioned going
going back to the 1950s during that
period of enormous growth in the
research university we had lots of
discussions even back then some of you
may have heard something called the
Farmington plan the farmington plane was
an effort in the research library
community to actually assign
responsibility among the major research
libraries to build collections in a
complementary way it failed we continued
to suggest to our faculty and to our
administration's that research libraries
actually work together to build
collections it's a lie we don't we need
to and therefore the concept of radical
collaboration I think has come to the
fore that the the ability to to really
integrate a lot of our collection
development strategies our staffing and
our resources is probably going to be
the only way that we're going to be able
to to build this coordinated approach
we've tried for 60 years to do it and we
basically have failed in our ability to
to coordinate the development those
international collections sometimes in
our thinking about global resources we
tend to put too much focus on the
selection and acquisition side clearly
our ability to get the material and to
select the material of the highest
quality and most relevance to the work
of students and scholars is at the very
front end of this process but we also
none to understand that the investment
that we as research libraries make
extend through a whole range of
activities in terms of if you will
cataloging it enabling people to find it
being able to share it and distribute it
working with our scholars and students
so they can understand and interpret of
this material making sure that it is
applied into the teaching and learning
and research and scholarship
environments and the one area that we
probably have had the biggest failure is
our ability to archive this material
going forward we generally have worked
focused our attention on the unique and
special materials in terms of the
long-term preservation of collections
and as we're seeing more and more if you
will born digital content web sites
email other things which are if you will
substituting or replacing the
traditional paper-based ways in which
organizations and people have worked we
have sort of a total failure in terms of
our ability to capture organize and
archive of the born digital record and I
will argue later that we have not only a
gap a major gap in terms of scholars
ability to work in this period because
of the absence and loss of born digital
content but we're seeing the whole
integrity of the scholarly communication
scholarly publishing infrastructure
eroded if I write a paper on a
particular topic I publish it in a
peer-reviewed journal and half of my
sources are in fact electronic sources
and you come to my work and you want to
test out my ideas and look at my
evidence but half of those electronic
resources have gone disappeared been
taken down moved change you have to
question the integrity of my work and I
believe the whole infrastructure is at
risk unless we address address that
fundamental problem but even as
libraries have those sort of if you will
traditional roles we're also taking on a
variety of new roles in
anse abilities and I would argue these
are important in terms of in advancing
your Asian Studies advancing scholarship
and learning but they also are diverting
resources from some of the traditional
areas in which we have worked so
libraries have learned how to come
together to negotiate with publishers as
consumers for content for better price
for better terms getting those
publishers if you will to to use
standardized processes for distributing
describing and preserving their work so
we've had some impact but we devote a
lot of energy to those negotiations
we're trying to sort of readapt a
concept of the 1960s called readers
advisors when faculty and students
approach libraries and said we need your
help librarian and understanding the
newly published work and understanding
what's really good and what's really not
relevant to my work and so we're trying
to reposition the library as an as an
intermediary in the scholarly process as
an aggregator of the the most important
and most valuable work we're also taking
on major work as publishers both
publishers in the traditional sense but
more importantly in our digital library
collections as we convert large
quantities of our historical analog
materials and publish them on the web
we're learning that we are not just
serving our own faculty and students at
our own institutions but when we publish
on the web the world becomes our user
community that means we're being
diverted if you will in terms of
answering questions and following up in
supporting users all over the world new
roles in the classroom new
understandings of how individuals
scholars students use collections and
apply collections so we're trying to
develop much more of an RD research and
development capacity we're trying to
leverage our assets assets of space and
content and infrastructure and
technology to bring new revenue streams
into the library and as I mentioned we
are facing a whole host of policy issues
copyright telecommunications privacy
intellectual freedom
information public funding for library
of congress neh etc etc and so therefore
were active in Albany were active in
Washington were active in Geneva and so
I point this out only to demonstrate
that the library that you work with at
your institution is being pulled in lots
of interesting and important directions
that may or may not enhance your ability
to do your work in your Asian
scholarship and so I've created this
taxonomy if you will of how do we look
at the research library today and going
forward clearly we have this legacy
responsibility we are responsible for
decades if not centuries of material
that we need to preserve and continue to
make available to you and to students
and scholars we do have to sustain an
infrastructure of technology and
infrastructure of expertise an infant
structure of space we have this
long-term repository role of society
sees libraries today as continuing to
have some fundamental responsibility for
not only preserving the content but as
content moves forward through technology
preserving your ability to access and
use that content going forward so we
have a functionality responsibility
that's been added to our content
responsibility we are a portal a gateway
if you will to the information of the
most relevance and quality that supports
your work we've got this enterprise this
rd this fundraising this resource
development responsibility and we are
one of the few agencies that actually is
representing the public interest in a
lot of these national and international
debates on issues of information policy
one of the things that libraries have
slowly learned to do over the last
decade is to build a greater capacity
for assessment we're being asked by our
universities we're being asked by our
state governments were being asked by
the grant funding agencies in Washington
some hard questions
as to whether we are relevant whether we
have impact and many of us have moved to
develop full-time offices of assessment
with staff who are trained in those
areas and not just to be responsive to
these sometimes asinine questions that
are coming out about our work but more
importantly to work with our faculty and
our students to better understand their
needs and to improve the support that we
provide and so in our work here at
Columbia as well as in other major
research libraries these are the types
of things we've learned about the
importance of the student experience
what we're learning obviously new
experiences every day in the classroom
and on your campuses no limits of time
and space no lines lots of if you will
sandboxie type of expectations in terms
of working with content and working with
with technology one of the biggest
challenges we're facing at Columbia and
it's true I think across the university
and college communities is we've
developed and supported these rich
information environments and then
students graduate and they go off
somewhere maybe they land in a graduate
school where they've got two great great
resources but very often they end up in
government or corporate or other types
of settings where suddenly they're cut
off from these information environments
that they enjoyed and benefited from we
also know that people want to control
their space they want to control their
information environments and we think
that this is very helpful in as we build
library collections and services
particularly through technology to
understand and support of what our
students need and want but we've had
similar experiences and working and
talking with our faculty this is sort of
a list of the things that we've learned
from our faculty at Columbia and which
has been affirmed by similar studies at
other institutions this is what faculty
Ellis is really important and meaningful
to their success and their advancement
in their careers at an institution so we
need to ask the question of how do we
measure why
is going forward do we measure libraries
by the number of people come in the
front door do we measure libraries by
the number of hits on our website do we
measure it by the number of items that
have been circulated out of the print
collection or do we begin to see
ourselves as measured in terms of
graduate success faculty productivity
and how do we draw those lines that is
something we're beginning to understand
learn and perhaps be able to act on and
as we build eurasian collections how do
how are we talking with you and with
your students and how are we
understanding whether what we're doing
not just locally but in relationship to
other academic research libraries is
enabling your students to be successful
and you to be productive as scholars I
think these are very hard questions but
it's the very question so that we need
to be asking this is challenged this is
a taxonomy that I developed about 2000
2001 I think it's still a relevant way
to talk about the relationship between
librarians and faculty i would say that
when i was born as a librarian i found
myself in a very servant relationship
with the faculty at the university at
which i worked i think over the period
of discord in some ways we developed as
strangers of faculty and students sort
of lived in parallel worlds and we sort
of lobbed things back and forth across
the campus to each other but there
wasn't this deep collaborative partner
and I think we're beginning to see a
period where we're moving away from the
what I would call a friendship stage two
and hopefully avoiding the customer
stage and really building sort of the
partner team relationship between
librarian and faculty member we think
the ability to continue to advance
international collections eurasian
collections at the major colleges and
research universities in this country
means that librarians and faculty have
to think of themselves as working side
by side and therefore i think we've got
to break some of that has
Oracle baggage which has defined those
relationships this always provokes
faculty in interesting ways so it's not
just a matter of content of Charles
Kuralt of the late newscaster once
observed that thanks to the interstate
highway system in the United States I
can travel from New York to San
Francisco and see absolutely nothing
content is important that's clear that's
sort of the infrastructure but what
we're hearing from our users is that as
we build these collections access is
critical we need to be able to do new
things that we've never been able to do
before in the classroom and in our
research everyone is trying to manage
productivity individually and
organizationally and I want to control
the information environments I don't
want the librarians that control my
information environment I want to
control my information environment so
give me the tools and capacities to do
that effectively and I think this user
expectations scenario which has
developed during the during the period
of what i call the what I called the
period of decadence where more and more
information was being pushed out I think
needs needs a lot more attention and a
lot more development so let me lay out
some assumptions as we begin to hone it
a little bit more on the collection side
of this we have to get I suspect that we
never had the capacity but it was part
of the fiction that we presented to you
and to the administration's that we
could develop comprehensive collections
in all formats at the major research
libraries in North America even Harvard
and Daris a new york public has stepped
up over the last decade to look at new
ways new roles and new new relationships
i think that as we build our collections
we're going to continue to be jerked
around if you will by the vagaries of
the university process
um academic priorities and funding
realities are going to mean that it's
going to be an up-and-down thing and our
ability to sustain our support of
maintain our support in a particular
area particularly when we take on if you
will a national collection role is going
to be creasing Lee challenged and so the
dependencies of the past in the present
I think will erode pretty dramatically
going forward collaborative collection
development i think is going to be
continued to be a marginalised area I
think we're trying to understand it
where we have new data which enables us
to understand our collective and
comparative strengths and weaknesses but
the ability to act on that
complementarity is unclear and I think
we're seeing much more of a honing in on
the distinctive and unique collections
particularly as more and more of the
historical literature becomes more
generally available through google and
other mass production strategies when
all of that historical literature is
available to everyone in a relatively
easy way we're learning that it's the
unique materials the buck native
archives if you will cast that out
across the the broader community that's
going to define what what is a research
library going forward also I think
because of the economy and because of
the just the scope of the challenge of
preservation and archiving we're going
to continue to see I think a somewhat
balkanized and almost by default
condition that's unfortunate there used
to be a lot of leadership and financial
support coming out of Washington to
enable us to preserve collections and
now a zippy has become far more
complicated and far more challenging
from a technology and financial
perspective we're seeing the resources
available to do it eroding even further
we also as I mentioned earlier seeing
National Information policy issues that
is our ability to move collections
across borders increasingly compromised
whether it's the Internet policies of
of countries that block access to
information that force the takedown of
born digital content think of China
think of Egypt whether it's the
copyright policies that limit the
ability of libraries to send materials
around the world you would think that in
the current information environment the
current technology environment when we
acquire something electronically at
Columbia and someone at liberal college
liberal arts college why wants a copy of
that article we could just send it to
them electronically well we can't we
can't legally I'll tell you here that we
find ways to do it but we in fact are
expected to actually print it off before
we actually communicate it now that
doesn't make any sense in this world but
those are the types of limits and
challenges that we're facing we're also
learning that in the absence of the
research library community to
collectively work with faculty to build
sort of like these new disciplinary
multidisciplinary information
environments we're finding pockets of
faculty and researchers of setting up
their own discovery and dissemination
and content management strategies so
we're seeing a tremendous not a
coordinated approach but a balkanization
within pockets of the disciplines that
within pockets of the regional studies
areas where everyone's coming up with
their own solutions in terms of managing
and accessing electronic information a
great example is the archive at Cornell
where for decades the physics and
computer science communities have
developed this depository this
repository if you will for all the
research in their areas of interest and
the stuffs it's they're not in journals
not in books not in government websites
but in a particular particular interest
of the high-energy physics computer
science community and you cast that out
by thousands of disciplinary
repositories around the world each set
up and each behaving in their own way
you get sort of a chaotic approach of
the scholarship that used to be
supported through the work of research
libraries we also know that our ability
to Bill
and maintained and serviced these
collections is increasingly possible
through traditional of MLS masters of
library science degree librarians we're
finding that the the depth of expertise
that the disciplinary expertise the
world region expertise that we need to
work with faculty and students in these
areas is not always available of with
individuals who have the master's degree
in library science and therefore we're
seeing a very different community of
librarians step forward to begin to take
on some of these responsibilities and I
I wrote an article several years ago
that got me into a lot of trouble and
that's a good thing the name of the
article was raised by wolves of the new
feral professional in the academic
library and what I observed I did not
advocate but what I observed was that
we're seeing more and more individuals
taking on professional library roles
with a diverse set of academic
credentials largely PhDs who are
stepping in for a variety of career
reasons to see the the academic library
as a place to build out a career and
bringing their expertise language
subject expertise and matching it
against the needs of the community we
also have this enormous explosion in the
other types of professional assignments
which are in the academic research
library space planners human resource
specialist web developers instructional
technologist fundraisers I mean you can
go on and on and on so it's it's not
just a group of MLS train librarians who
are working with the library with the
faculty to develop the collections
there's a probably forty percent of
professional staffs in most academic
libraries around the country in fact do
not have of the master's degree in
library science and it's creating I
think some really interesting hybrid
cultural issues and environments
that we're learning how to figure out so
I I ask your indulgence for the use of
the word two point oh there but I think
it's a way to sort of provoke us to
recognize that the subject librarians
that we were are not the subject
librarians that we are or will be and as
I look at the role in nature of the
librarians who work in academic research
libraries those who are in fact carrying
out the development of Eurasian and
other international collections there
are some really provocative thoughts
that came to mind as I as I brainstorm
this there's an interesting issue of
Allegiance does the librarian align him
or herself with the academic department
with the Institute if you will or do
they see themselves as part of the
library that's an interesting social
problem that we're trying to work
through we also know that there's this
sharing of responsibilities going on you
you probably are aware that in the case
of rob davis he actually is the Russian
East European Slavic Eurasian Central
Asian East European etc etc librarian
for both columbia and cornell and so he
he is supporting the faculty and
students at two universities through his
role here at columbia under what we call
the two cool project columbia university
libraries and cornell university
libraries therefore to cool we also are
ready to accept the third institution I
should ask ed so claremont or catholic
or colgate can step forward if they want
to and we already have our acronym
worked out its tre cool so we also I've
developed the concept of the embedded
professional when I was at Johns Hopkins
I worked there before i came to columbia
we basically had closed the health
sciences library and we had moved all
the librarians all the information
professionals out into the laboratories
of the teaching departments the bedside
if you will of the of the medical campus
and we're be seeing more and more of
that now beginning to happen not only in
the science
but also in the social science at
humanities fields as well so how do how
do the librarians become a more integral
part of the working relationships within
the teaching and research departments we
also know we've got this deep survival
challenge that we're facing the private
institutions went through it over the
last two or three years largely because
of the endowment of issues now we're
seeing the public universities if you
look at some of the big 10 schools in
the University of California for example
of what were in fact extraordinary
research institutions with great
research collections they're having to
make some hard choices in terms of what
they'll support and what they're able
able to fund and there's a lot of
question marks in terms of going forward
what the next three to five years will
look like we're also finding that this
whole concept of research information
management it's not just buying the
collections so our faculty and students
can use them but more how do we enter
and participate in the process of
organizing the data and the evidence and
working with the faculty to enable them
to publish successfully in this
information environment we for example
have created a center here called the
center for digital research and
scholarship which is a team of
individuals who actually work with our
researchers and our faculty to negotiate
more effectively with publishers to
create spaces in which they can publish
books online publish open access
journals and so forth so it's a it's a
real interesting new role a rim we call
it rim research information management
function that libraries are taking
taking on I mentioned the the percentage
of researchers and students at Columbia
that in fact come from other countries
and have expectations that we will be
able to provide materials published in
their home countries and in the
languages that they've worked with and I
think our capacity to do that at
Columbia and if you cast that out across
the colleges and universities in North
America that host large numbers of
international students and researchers
our ability to provide that support is
increasingly
increasingly compromised we also are
trying to see if we can play a more
effective role in educating our own
students as they go abroad lots of
institutions have built a pretty
aggressive strategies to require or at
least have high expectations for their
undergraduate students to spend a
certain period of time working outside
the United States I was at Notre Dame
for a number of years and I know that
they have a very I think almost eighty
percent of their of their students
undergraduate students end up for some
portion of their undergraduate life
outside we we think that the ability of
universities to sustain a rigorous and
relatively comprehensive foreign
language education program is
fundamental is integral to our building
of foreign language collections if we
don't have students undergraduate and
graduate students who can work with
these languages why are we building
these collections so we're beginning to
raise i think concerns about whether we
should have on what the number is but we
catalogued over 160 languages in the
library collections at columbia last
year Princeton and New York Public I'm
sure in the same same ballpark of why
why are we doing this well we continue
to feel we have a national role in
responsibility but the capacity of our
community may not be able to take
advantage of those resources we've got
this phenomena of the global campus and
the research center lots of debate and
play in the higher education literature
about the saturday or insanity of these
of these global ventures Columbia's
taken the position that we're not going
to build campuses of a broad but build
the search centers places sort of
footprints if you will around the world
where we can actually create
opportunities for our faculty and
students to interact with counterparts
in those world areas I think the jury's
still out in terms of the success and
viability of that overall strategy that
is we haven't figured out how to pay for
it and therefore I think lots of
university
as they move outside the United States
bump up against sort of economic
political social realities that maybe
they hadn't planned for think of the
universities that have major centers in
the Middle East and how they've been
challenged in the current situation and
we've already talked about the user
behaviors oclc I assume you you've heard
of the WorldCat database this was a
major bibliographic resource starting in
the late 1970s I'm required to tell you
that I am on the board of OCLC but I do
think it's a great tool and one of the
important elements of WorldCat and OCLC
over the last decade has been the
internationalization and libraries
research libraries and national
libraries all over the world are
contributing their build a graphic
records to the WorldCat database now
less than fifty percent of the holdings
in WorldCat in fact our English language
materials and so it's raised the
prospect among faculty and students of
their ability to get their hands on lots
of international materials because of
the you know the general availability
and use of the WorldCat database it's
the tool through which we manage
interlibrary loan in a lot of our
research libraries and a lot of our
academic libraries around the United
States and again those policy issues
that are being raised to block access
across international borders is creating
some interesting problems we should get
into a debate at some point over the
continuing over the survival of the
print journal and the survival of the
print book as we know it I think there's
some interesting economic and academic
trends which are pushing us in a pretty
rapidly in a direction where we have to
question whether 10 years from now the
analog format for scholarly
communication will will will in fact be
viable the a journal revolution took
about 20 years so starting at about
nineteen ninety we saw
lots of the scientific technical and
medical literature begin to move online
and over the and I was involved with the
founding and advancement of project Muse
at Johns Hopkins which was the first
real venture into the electronic
publishing of humanities journals and
now i think twenty years later 2010 one
could sort of declare the revolution is
over that means doesn't mean that
they're still not lots of print journals
sitting around library collections but
it's been enormously depleted and we're
seeing much of the journal literature
captured the back files captured
electronically so we have raised
questions about the continuing
warehousing of print journals within our
central libraries and now we're
beginning to see a real rigorous debate
over the future of the extended argument
in print of the scholarly monograph as
we know it I think it's going to be a
revolution it's going to move much
faster and the reason it's going to move
much faster is the people who are
walking down Broadway today have no idea
what electronic journal is that's our
province and it took us about 20 years
to make that change but they know what
books are and so the electronic book
because of the consumer and commercial
aspect of this potentially would move
will move much more quickly and we can
debate the pros and cons of reading
online and so forth but I think there's
a certain inevitability that people want
to be able to search at least of books
online if not necessarily read them
online this has been fuel to a large
extent by these mass digitization
projects where we've seen millions I
think we're somewhere in the area 14 to
16 million historical volumes that have
been digitized those which are out of
copyright are generally available online
through most of our libraries and we're
working pretty aggressively in the
library community to out the in
copyright stuff recognizing that there
are certain intricacies of American
copyright law that in fact enable us to
open up in copyright content
and we're doing a lot of research
collaboratively to try to try to make
that happen I've talked a little bit
about the websites and I do want to talk
about the cyber infrastructure a little
bit we we've got this sort of GIS
revolution going on to geographic
information systems where it used to be
that the public health folks and the
business folks used to want to come into
our libraries and to map data against
geography but we're now finding that all
disciplines are increasingly interested
in that type of geo analysis we're
seeing a lot more historians a lot more
political scientists come in and work
with with that and as more and more of
the data is coming out of different
world areas as more of the census data
economic data population data public
health data comes in from around the
world people want to do the deep type of
analysis that the GIS GIS technologies
and systems enable I've talked a little
bit about the websites and the real
difficulty of capturing and archiving
and making that available I've talked a
little bit about repositories it's of
great interest to me of the chaotic
environment we've created in terms of
where you and where scholars are putting
their work scholars used to put it into
what I call the publisher repository and
we could depend on that was the place
that we went to access and use
information usually it was a printed
object increasingly now it's a database
but it's still owned and served by the
publisher but people are putting it up
on their own websites their own work
they're putting it up on institutional
repositories Columbia academic commons
they're putting it up on disciplinary
repositories repositories of which there
are thousands they're putting it into
government repositories in some
countries there's a mandate to put stuff
into national repositories and so I
think we're creating the sort of chaotic
environment of the output of scholars
not sure which one I site which one will
survive which one's the right one which
one hasn't been changed
so it's a real interesting problem which
I think scholarship faces and I think
each discipline those who work in
different world areas have got to be got
to be concerned we're at a very good
point for me to do this slide and then
to take a break and let me come back and
share with you some provocative thinking
about where I think we're going what
I've tried to lay out is sort of the
historical and perhaps better the
current state of the ability of research
libraries to build organize curate and
archive international materials and the
larger context of the users the faculty
and students in those communities and so
what I've tried to do now is to say okay
I'm not just going to sort of define the
problems what I'd also like to do is
encourage us to think about where there
might be solutions and I don't think the
solutions are viable at the
institutional level I think we've got to
build out a more collaborative if you
will radical strategy for helping us to
sustain our ability to support teaching
and learning research and publishing in
these international fields so oclc
having brought in all of this content
from the world's libraries I think gives
us the ability to at least understand
the collections that exist what is out
there who has it in what number of
copies where are the unique holdings
where are the collections of depth and
breadth which define our ability to do
our work we have an organization called
spark you may have heard it from your
librarians it's the scholarly publishing
and academic resources coalition it was
at a meeting in 1996 when we were sort
of all wringing our hands at the
association of research libraries
meeting and say oh woe is us the
publishers are messing it up again and
we sort of collectively threw open the
window and said we're mad as hell and
we're not going to take it anymore and
we created this thing called spark and
spark has been our collective lobbying
effort
a collective advocacy effort to push
back against the publishers and saying
that we need to develop national scholar
communication systems that don't just
depend on for-profit publishers to get
the information out and shared among
students and scholars around the world
can spark play a role in helping us
think about new systems for scholarly
publishing and scholarly communication
the association of research libraries I
think has a very central role in helping
us the research library community to
think differently about where we are
going because I think we've understood
that the the capacities of our
individual efforts will not hold up and
we've got to find ways to transform not
only how we behave at the local level
but how we in fact interact and work
together the digital library Federation
is another expression of a collective
policy effort based in Washington I was
at a meeting of that group last Thursday
which is trying to understand what all
this mass digitization activity means
what does it mean when 15 million
volumes of historical material have
digit has been digitized how do we make
sure that if we come to depend on that
and that becomes our central point of
access to this information that it in
fact doesn't get taken over by profit
sector and doesn't get lost if you will
because we're facing as I'll say after
the break some major decisions in terms
of how we're going to react to this
environment the Library of Congress
which maintains some offices around
around the world for acquiring materials
on behalf of the research library
community I think can help us think
differently about the support and
coordination of our foreign acquisitions
efforts they're actually pulling back
from some of that activity at the very
point when I think they need to be
stepping out in helping us deal with
that better the center for research
libraries it's a chicago-based
organization built in the 1950s with
about 200 library members they've
created something called the global
resources network in which they're
trying to build partnerships between
American research libraries in different
libraries so there's a Latin American
product
a German project and so forth that
African newspapers project and so forth
where they're trying to make sure that
we work with the with the organization's
communities at the local level to
capture that material so that we don't
lose it and it can be made available to
students and scholars in the US and then
the Council on library and information
resources I'm arguing again which is a
washington-based collaborative really
should help us build an overall strategy
for how we're going to maintain our
global resources capacity so individual
libraries in my view have got to come
together as part of these collaborative
structures in order to make sure that
you and your students continued have
access to the International materials
that you need to do to do your work and
so we should take a break and when we
come back let me let me push around a
little bit some ideas in terms of where
we might go